you guys you have I want to ask you
about we have a picture here of a stunt
that I don't even know what's happening
here it looks like you're you're holding
hands which is fine but you're you're in
the Earth's orbit almost is that right
or you couldn't be obviously you're
you're how high up are you
that was a 33,000 feet 33,000 feet
yeah well above the Mont Blanc the
tallest mountain in Europe we are doing
a special journey of Heath Ledger where
we are using oxygen masks and we are
jumping at the height of a liner and a
liner you know so it's yeah 50 degree
that's an amazing shot yeah it's
beautiful guys and and where did you
land on the grass field at the bottom of
the Montaigne okay alright anti-climatic
ending of the story that's my fault
that's on man a galloping horse I know
that's how I got it
a galloping white horse with wings a
unique honor yeah a uniform I wanted you
want to land very carefully on a unicorn
it's it's not legal and it's not illegal
it's just in between you guys are
incredible you're absolutely incredible
I like you guys so I want you to be safe
do you know what your next trick is you
know what you're going to do what I want
to call it trick stunts well we have
some different ideas we would like to
fly above Paris and make some flyby next
to the Eiffel Tower or maybe next time
fly and just land straight into the in
here you know I can oh you want to land
in here yeah yeah yeah well you got to
wait in line with these people
[Laughter]
this shows too good you can't just I'm
so happy for both you for more amazing
videos follow Red Bull on Facebook the
SOL Flyers these guys are incredible
Fred you Jenny
thanks for payback Albert Hammond Jr
you